I should do no anything to help with tonight's. I have tried several natural methods of
no avail. It seems nothing from conventional medicine. Yeah, tonight is, there is no easy fix
for tonight's. Because tonight is now thought to be actually inflammation of the auditory nerve
and inflammation. It can be inflammation in your brain. So there is a, I have a blog post called
if you go to our blog and you look up neuroinflammation, I created a video, it's about a half-hour video
on neuroinflammation and microglial primate. I highly suggest you go and watch that.
That is what I have to do with tonight's because if you have inflammation in the temporal
lobe of the brain, the sides of the brain, that's what your auditory center goes into.
If you have inflammation and microglial primate in there, that can be a cause of tonight's. So
treaty tonight is as an inflammatory disorder. It's probably your best bet. So going on
higher dose flavonoids, I would give that a try. I would also give a try to delta-total
treatle, which is the center, the center portion of the vitamin E. There's four central components of
that. Those are called the total treatles. Delta-total treatle could be good for the ear. So
not to get too technical, but you have certain parts of your body. You have vascularization
eating vessels that are feeding it. That's your source of oxygen to that tissue. Those vessels are
what are called terminal vessels. So terminal vessels means you only have one vessel that goes to
that area. You don't have other vessels. When you have tissues that have other vessels, those are
called anastamosine vessels. So you have other sources of fuel, in this case oxygen, to that tissue.
Well, in the inner ear, and in the heart, you have, that's two main parts of your body,
that's your only terminal vessels. And when you have constriction of those vessels,
that's usually due to inflammation in the underneath the lining of the vessel, which is the endothelial
layer. You have smooth muscle, and you can get inflammation in there. It causes contraction of
smooth muscle, and you have contraction in those vessels, and you have an impediment of flow
through that vessel, which causes a lack of oxygen, which causes damage. If it's in your heart,
you have to have a heart attack. Well, in your ear, you can end up with loss of hearing and
tenditis. So that can be an issue. Well, the Delta Tocotriotol, which is that center part of the
vitamin E, could be very helpful to help open that up. So I would try Delta Tocotriotols.
So remember, it's not just vitamin E, because that's going to be an alpha to cough or all,
or alpha-bated Delta Tocotriotol. That's not what you want. So you want the center part of the
vitamin E. I would also watch that video, neural inflammation and microbial primate that'll explain
call me down the inflammatory cytokine response in the brain, which could be in the temporal lobe,
causing the tinnitus, which you use high-dose flavonoids, which are flavonoids are like
curcumin, porcelain, bromelain, stingy denols, anti-inflammatories, resveratrol, EDCG, things like that.
So watch that video that they give you some clues, too.